le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
pour des milliers de familles
réunionnaises une question revient
souvent que mange nos enfants à la
cantine sécurité alimentaire traçabilité
des aliments composition des menus d'où
viennent les produits qui seront
consommés par les enfants une idée
simple serait que les cantines locales
ne soient approvisionnées que par les
produits de l'agriculture locale avec le
double avantage d'apporter une ressource
à une agriculture qui en a bien besoin
et de garantir la qualité et la
provenance des produits malgré les
difficultés de mise en place ce principe
simple et performant existe déjà grâce à
une initiative ambitieuse les cantines
pays avec les produits pays on en parle
maintenant dans le lien social
cette collège Titan dans la ville du
Port que se trouve la cuisine centrale
de la zone ouest tous les jours à partir
de 6 heures du matin le personnel de
cuisine réceptionne des tonnes de
marchandises un ballet de camions
contenant chacun des produits différents
mais ces produits ont un point commun
ils sont tous issus d'agriculteurs
locaux une fois réceptionné ces
quantités impressionnantes de
marchandises sont travaillées ici même
par des ouvriers très qualifiés chaque
matin c'est cette équipe de 20 personnes
qui cuisinent des produits réunionnais
pour des enfants réunionnais
les légumes les fruits les viandes
bovines les volailles et autres sont
élevés et cultivés localement tous ces
aliments finiront dans les assiettes
d'environ 8000 enfants chaque jour un
système et des chiffres qui font la
fierté de Jean Raymond kamlindien chef
responsable de la cuisine centrale c'est
en 1900 depuis quelques temps sur
l'économie de la Réunion et en
particulier en légumes et en viande
fraîches les légumes nous avons un
marché un tn ici avec un groupement de
producteurs donc on travaille avec des
gens qui font de l'agriculture raisonnée
en produits pays nous avons aussi un
deuxième marché que le marché gala celui
du lycée les avirons ou là aussi on a un
marché en produits pays mais en légumes
de quatrième gamme c'est-à-dire des
légumes qui arrivent déjà prête à
l'emploi ce que vous avez vu ce matin en
dans les marmites nous avons aussi mis
l'absence sur les viandes toutes nos
viandes sont essentiellement fraîches la
viande de volaille nous arrive
directement de chez aVICOM pendant les
cours l'essentiel le boeuf nous
travaillons qu'une boucherie du coin qui
est la boucherie Edmond où on travaille
en bœuf pays
la pâte celle-là bon on essaie de faire
un maximum vraiment tout ce qu'on peut
pour travailler avec l'économie de la
Réunion
c'est à l'initiative de la présidente du
conseil général Nassima dadar qu'une
convention a été proposée et signée
entre les agriculteurs les producteurs
locaux et les cantines des collectivités
un système qui fait ses preuves car tous
les acteurs y trouvent leur intérêts
cette solidarité a beaucoup d'avantages
elle soutient l'agriculture pays qui par
conséquent maintient des emplois et au
final nous garantit la provenance des
produits que mange nos enfants
uniquement sur l'année
2012-2013 800 on va dire demi
pensionnaires supplémentaires grâce à
notre convention avec le Conseil Général
pour en faveur donc des produits locaux
voilà nous sommes bien sûr dans une
mission de restauration mais aussi par
là une fonction donc dans le cadre de
l'économie locale on se félicite de
travailler avec les agriculteurs avec
les producteurs locaux sont vraiment de
produits de meilleure qualité donc les
familles sont particulièrement
satisfaites les enfants on peut voir
donc les enfants n'ont que sont heureux
on va dire donc de pouvoir bénéficier de
ce service de restauration et cela dans
l'ensemble des établissements on va dire
donc de la zone ouest pour dire que la
cuisine que la cuisine centrale c'est le
plus grand restaurant scolaire aux
hauteur de la zone ouest de la réunion
des agriculteurs soutenus des cantines
fières de travailler des produits pays
des enfants heureux de manger une
cuisine traditionnelle avec des légumes
et des viandes exclusivement locales
tous les avantages de cette convention
offre à l'économie réunionnaise une
solution et une preuve qu'il est
possible de continuer à faire avancer
notre île tout en gardant notre addition
et plus encore de manière intelligente
et durable la Réunion est unie la
population jeune et il y a beaucoup de
rationnaires dans les cantines scolaires
du primaire jusqu'au secondaire
leur département a donc une
responsabilité forte pour promouvoir des
produits de consommation locale légumes
fruits féculents de manière à ce qui est
une pédagogie alimentaire qui finalement
fixeront les pratiques alimentaires de
ces jeunes pour l'avenir au plus grand
profit de l'agriculture réunionnaise et
ça ne concerne pas que le collège il
faut déjà dès l'enfance donc c'est un
travail collectif et l'ensemble des
collectivités doivent mesurer cette
responsabilité de telle sorte que les
millions de repas chaque année puissent
être fortement agrémenté de produits
locaux et les agriculteurs y sont
sensibles ont donc fixé avec nous des
objectifs forts dans le cas des cas
d'agriculture et il nous faut remplir
ces objectifs parce que c'est l'avenir
du Nil durable avec une alimentation
équilibrée parce que la réunion à cette
particularité d'une richesse dans son
dans sa culture alimentaire et il nous
faut donc faire que dans l'avenir le
développement durable passe par une
agriculture durable
l'efficacité de cette convention fait
ses preuves depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois elle en fait profiter nos enfants
et donc l'avenir de la Réunion cette
entente entre les agriculteurs et le
Conseil Général montre à la jeunesse
réunionnaise que la solidarité offre
beaucoup de solutions efficaces et
durables pour notre département
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais